Hi there, this is Will Arnett, host of the Will Arnett FunZone podcast. Hang on, hang on. Will. This week, what? We've talked about this, man. We've been over this like so many times. Okay. But we are doing it though, right?
大家好，我是Will Arnett，Will Arnett FunZone播客的主持人。等等，等等。Will。这周，怎么了？伙计，我们讨论过这个了。我们已经讨论过很多次了。好吧。但我们确实在做，对吧？
We are going to do that. No, no, we're not. This is SmartLess. Okay. FunZone. I know. Well, what are we doing today? All we need is a super simple welcome to SmartLess.
我们要去做那个。不，不，我们不做了。这是SmartLess。好吧。FunZone。我知道。那么，我们今天要做什么？我们只需要一个超级简单的SmartLess欢迎词。
Oh, right. I'm going to dig deep for this. Welcome to SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
哦，对了。我要深入挖掘一下。欢迎来到SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. Now, listen, Jason, before we get too deep into the show, we need to talk about the crew, the crew collar, and now you've, tell us what, walk us through what happened this morning. Well, I went ahead and I got showered and changed prior to our record for my golf engagement following this record. Oh, you go.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。现在，听着，Jason，在我们深入节目之前，我们需要谈谈工作人员，工作人员的领子，现在你，告诉我们，带我们回顾一下今天早上发生了什么。嗯，我在录制之前去洗了个澡，换了衣服，因为录制结束后我有高尔夫球局。哦，你去吧。
Yeah. Not proud to say, but Chuckles over there does it too. So yeah, so I put on my collared shirt as you're required to do, and then it's a little chilly here in Los Angeles. I put on a nice wrap over the top of it, a nice cashmere wrap, and the collar on that crew neck was a little tight. So it took the collar of my undershirt there and pushed it up, and then Will was hurting me calling it a mock turtleneck.
是的。说出来不光彩，但那边的Chuckles也这么做。所以，是的，我穿上了你必须穿的翻领衬衫，然后洛杉矶这里有点冷。我在外面套了一件漂亮的罩衫，一件漂亮的羊绒罩衫，那个圆领的领口有点紧。所以它把我的内衣领子往上推了，然后Will就嘲笑我，叫它假高领。
So that sweater's gone. I'm going to go to a V-neck. And Will said we were talking about money for producing the podcast, and Will said, what's the budget for a mock turtleneck for Jason for the coming out of the budget? I've already matched it. It's a fair question. First of all, you're allowed to mock a mock turtleneck. It's built into the name.
所以那件毛衣没了。我要换成V领的。Will说我们在谈论制作播客的预算，Will说，Jason的假高领预算是多少？从预算里出吗？我已经匹配了。这是一个公平的问题。首先，你被允许嘲笑假高领。这名字里就自带了。
But by the way, you'll never see me in a mock turtleneck. You'll never see me in a turtleneck for sure, because I've got probably, they ask you sometimes, what's the one thing you change about your body? It's probably my non-superhero jawline. I've got sort of a diagonal from the end of my chin to my Adam's apple as opposed to a 90 degree thing. So if I wear a turtleneck, I then have the turkey goblet hangover over the edge, the cascades, the skin, the cascades over the edge of the turtleneck.
但顺便说一句，你永远不会看到我穿假高领。你肯定永远不会看到我穿高领衫，因为我大概，他们有时会问你，你最想改变身体的哪个部位？可能是我那不怎么像超级英雄的下颌线。从下巴末端到喉结，我有一条斜线，而不是90度的线条。所以如果我穿高领衫，我的火鸡脖子就会挂在边缘，层层叠叠，皮肤层叠在高领衫的边缘。
I can't have it. Yeah. No, I get it. I disagree. You both have nice, nice silhouettes. Go back to the thing though, about being cold. It's cold in LA. I came down the stairs today.
我受不了。是的。不，我明白了。我不同意。你们俩都有很好、很好的轮廓。回到那个关于冷的话题吧。洛杉矶很冷。我今天下楼。
I'm not, not making this up. I came downstairs and Scotty had the heat, heat on, on the first floor Los Angeles and the heat. And I was sweating by the time I got to the bottom of it. You come down the stairs, your Hollywood house, every day like Gloria Swanson, right? That's right. And a flowing house coat. Yeah.
我不是，不是编的。我下楼时，Scotty在洛杉矶的一楼开了暖气，暖气。我走到楼下时已经出汗了。你每天像Gloria Swanson一样走下你那好莱坞房子的楼梯，对吧？没错。穿着飘逸的家居服。是的。
I'm ready for my close-up. It's so great to see you guys. It's so great to see you guys too. This is really exciting. I'm excited for you guys to talk to our guest today. Oh, I am excited to listen. Because our guest is somebody, it's a, this is a mega talent. This person is a person who's been doing it for a long time.
我准备好拍特写了。见到你们真是太好了。见到你们也太好了。这真的很令人兴奋。我很兴奋你们能和我们今天的嘉宾交谈。哦，我很兴奋能听。因为我们的嘉宾是某个人，这是一个，这是一个超级天才。这个人是一个已经从事这一行很久的人。
This person is not just an actor. This person is a writer. This person is a skilled musician who started playing violin at the age of three. They can play the piano, accordion, trombone, guitar, harmonica, and has written and improvised music a lot in a show that they've done now for many, many years. This person received an honorary doctorate from performing arts from Merrimack College. This person, you know, was active at Williamstown Theatre Festival back in the day. This person has gone on to a huge career in television in, I guess, the longest running
这个人不仅仅是一个演员。这个人是一个作家。这个人是一位熟练的音乐家，三岁就开始拉小提琴。他们会弹钢琴、手风琴、长号、吉他、口琴，并且在他们做了很多很多年的节目中写过很多即兴音乐。这个人获得了梅里马克学院颁发的表演艺术荣誉博士学位。这个人，你知道，以前在威廉斯敦戏剧节很活跃。这个人后来在电视界拥有了巨大的职业生涯，我想，是有史以来最长寿的
TV comedy of all time. This person has- Well, it has to be slow down here. I want to, I want to do some guesses here. I know. Well, this is, this is my guess and it makes sense because this is my friend and I'm so happy to have my friend and I want you guys to start trying to guess. This person has done lots of movies.
电视喜剧。这个人有——好吧，这里得慢一点。我想，我想在这里猜一猜。我知道。好吧，这是，这是我的猜测，这很有道理，因为这是我的朋友，我很高兴有我的朋友，我希望你们开始尝试猜测。这个人拍过很多电影。
This person was in the Lego movie with me. This is Charlie Day. Longest running comedy movie. The Lego movie, too. Yeah. Pacific Rim. Longest running comedy. Horrible Bosses and its sequel.
这个人和我一起拍了《乐高大电影》。这是Charlie Day。最长寿的喜剧电影。《乐高大电影2》。是的。《环太平洋》。最长寿的喜剧。《恶老板》及其续集。
Well, it's got to be Chuck Day. And Beth Noor Forest's show. It's Charlie Day. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. All right. You're scraping the bottom of the barrel now, boys. No, I was-
好吧，那一定是Chuck Day。还有Beth Noor Forest的节目。是Charlie Day。天哪。天哪。好吧。伙计们，你们现在是在刮地皮了。不，我当时——
Time to wrap the show up. So, Chuck, what about, this is, now, I think the reason you've taken so long to book, on this, is your schedule, right? It took a real long time for someone to ask me. I think that's what it was. I can't believe Rob McElhaney beat you onto this show. Oh, that's nonsense. What does that say about us?
是时候结束节目了。所以，Chuck，关于这个，现在，我想你花这么长时间才预订上这个节目，是因为你的日程安排，对吧？花了好长时间才有人邀请我。我想就是这样。我不敢相信Rob McElhaney比你先上这个节目。哦，那是一派胡言。这说明了我们什么？
Here's, here's my favorite part. Is that Bateman and Chuck Day have been friends for many years. They've done a few movies together and I was so happy to steal Charlie as my guest from under Bateman, just, just to really put it- I would have had him on, too. I know. I think maybe you did ask me. Yeah, definitely.
这是，这是我最喜欢的部分。Bateman和Chuck Day已经做了很多年的朋友了。他们一起拍了几部电影，我很高兴能从Bateman手下抢走Charlie作为我的嘉宾，只是，只是为了真正地——我也会邀请他的。我知道。我想也许你确实邀请过我。是的，肯定。
And then you were saying, yeah, gosh, you know, I don't know. We're starting a podcast and I, I think you gave me a little bit of a run around and I don't, I don't like to pressure people. I know you were looking to get paid quite a bit of money for today. Yeah. I was waiting for you guys to make money so I could start making money, which is cool because Will cut me a great check for this. I had to send him over cash, a guy with a rucksack full of cash.
然后你说，是的，天哪，你知道，我不知道。我们要开始做播客了，我，我想你有点敷衍我，我不，我不喜欢给别人施加压力。我知道你今天想赚一大笔钱。是的。我一直在等你们赚钱，这样我就可以开始赚钱了，这很酷，因为Will为此给我开了一张很棒的支票。我不得不给他寄现金，一个背着装满现金的背包的家伙。
Yeah. And that's a pay cut for me, guys. Because you're not doing that well, right? You know, that show is not paying you. I've made a lot of bad decisions though. You know what I mean? I've made a lot of sketchy calls. Wait, we had, Charlie, we had Macklehanion and, and, and what, is it really the longest
是的。这对我是减薪，伙计们。因为你们做得不是很好，对吧？你知道，那个节目没给你钱。但我做了很多错误的决定。你知道我的意思吗？我做了很多草率的决定。等等，我们有，Charlie，我们有Macklehanion，还有，还有，真的是史上最长寿的
running sitcom in history? Yeah. Yeah. Well, years, if you don't count episodes, I think you, you did more episodes of Will and Grace in like two seasons. And they already did. How many years is it now? This is something we don't want to gloss over because this, this, this is, you should be,
情景喜剧吗？是的。是的。嗯，按年份算，如果你不算集数，我想你，你在两季里拍的《威尔和格蕾丝》集数更多。他们已经拍了。现在是多少年了？这是我们不想忽略的事情，因为这，这，这，你应该，
and I'm sure you are so proud of how long this show has been on the air. Yeah, it's so cool. This doesn't just make yourself. We're talking, of course, about all of a sudden. I mean, it's 15 years. We just, we just, 15 years. And you're about to do another one or two? I don't know, at least another one, and we'll see after that.
而且我相信你一定为这个节目播出这么久感到非常自豪。是的，太酷了。这不仅仅是成就你自己。我们当然是在谈论《费城永远阳光灿烂》。我是说，15年了。我们刚刚，我们刚刚，15年了。你还要再拍一两季吗？我不知道，至少再拍一季，之后再看。
Look at the way he's positioning right there. I know. He knows Fox is listening. Of course. That Vex or whatever the hell it is. Yeah. And he's going to jam him again. He's going to get up to 20.
看他现在的姿态。我知道。他知道福克斯在听。当然。那个Vex还是什么鬼东西。是的。他又要卡住他们了。他要拍到20季。
You know what it is? We've done a lot. I don't know how long we can keep it. Nothing adds more zeros than a foot out the door. Right? I mean, let's just sketch them. That's true. Yeah.
你知道那是什么吗？我们做了很多。我不知道我们还能坚持多久。没有什么比一只脚跨出门外更能增加零了。对吧？我是说，让我们草草了事。那是真的。是的。
So Charlie, let's talk a little bit about, because we were talking about all of a sudden in Philadelphia, which is a huge long running show, longest by years. Could you have imagined, take us back to the day when you actually, when it actually became a TV show, because we had Rob on here. We talked about it. You guys made some videos and stuff and you shot some stuff. Is that, am I remembering that correctly? And you took it to FX?
所以Charlie，让我们谈谈，因为我们刚才在谈论《费城永远阳光灿烂》，这是一个非常长寿的节目，按年份算最长。你能想象吗，带我们回到它真正成为电视节目的那天，因为我们请过Rob来这里。我们谈过这个。你们拍了一些视频之类的东西，你们拍了一些东西。是这样吗，我记得对吗？然后你们把它带到了FX？
Yeah. That's basically it. I mean, we were shooting in my apartment, which was on the corner of Western and Franklin there. I lived, and I think I paid 600 bucks a month for rent. You got Rob. Quick aside. Quick aside, Jason.
是的。基本上就是这样。我是说，我们在我的公寓里拍摄，就在Western和Franklin的拐角处。我住在那，我想我每个月付600美元的房租。你得到了Rob。快速插话。快速插话，Jason。
Last time you were east of Cuyenga. Five, four, three, two, one. Back in the drug days for sure. Yeah. I think I might have seen you scoring on the corner. Yeah. There was a pay phone I'd like to hang out at. I had to run you down a dime bag or something.
你上次去Cuyenga以东是什么时候。五，四，三，二，一。肯定是在吸毒的日子里。是的。我想我可能在拐角处看到你交易。是的。有一个公用电话我喜欢待在那里。我得给你弄点小袋装的东西之类的。
I'm not sure what it was. Oh my God. So you're in your apartment. Right. And was there a phone call from the, from your agent or, or a manager or something that said they bought it? You know what it was? So we had shot this thing and, and it was like pretty good, but we knew we'd sort of not
我不确定那是什么。天哪。所以你在你的公寓里。对。然后有没有来自你的经纪人，或者经理之类的电话说他们买了它？你知道那是什么吗？所以我们拍了这个东西，而且，而且它还挺不错的，但我们知道我们有点没
hit the nail on the head. And we had nothing really going on. So we redid the whole thing. We were doing it so cheaply. We were holding the cameras. We had a little boom that was, it was real low rent. And our second go around was pretty funny. We thought, oh, there's something here.
切中要害。而且我们真的没什么进展。所以我们重拍了整个东西。我们拍得太便宜了。我们拿着摄像机。我们有一个小吊杆，真的很低端。我们的第二次尝试很有趣。我们想，哦，这里面有东西。
And we were all at three arts management at the time. So like Nick Frankel and Michael Rotenberg took it to WME and they, they kind of sat on it for a while. They're like, yeah, maybe we'll, we'll hook you up with a big producer. And God, we waited forever for John Favreau to watch it. And he just, I guess he never got around to it. The one that got away. I know.
当时我们都在Three Arts Management。所以Nick Frankel和Michael Rotenberg把它带到了WME，他们，他们有点把它搁置了一段时间。他们说，是的，也许我们会，我们会给你找个大制片人。天哪，我们等John Favreau看它等了很久。我想他一直没空看。错失的机会。我知道。
Well, I mean, I'm so glad I'm not cutting half a check to John, you know, like, I mean, I'm sure he would have helped a lot, but, you know, it's nice not to have to be paying or anything. But, uh, eventually we got kind of bored and we shot a third episode. And literally you, you shot it because you were just in this waiting because the agencies are, so you just, you guys are on their timetable. Well, that, and the only thing to do on Western is either move the bag or shoot another episode. It should be, it should be noted.
好吧，我是说，我很高兴我不用给John分一半支票，你知道，我是说，我相信他会帮上大忙，但，你知道，不用付钱什么的也挺好的。但是，呃，最终我们有点无聊，我们拍了第三集。而且字面上是你，你拍了它，因为你只是在等待，因为经纪公司是，所以你们只是，你们是在他们的时间表上。好吧，那个，而且在Western上唯一能做的事要么是搬袋子，要么是拍另一集。应该，应该指出。
Can I just take this? Am I right in saying this? And you guys going to agree or disagree with me? The, the, the agent thing in, in a show business is hilarious because like you can't get in touch with your agent in the first thing in the morning because they're in a staff meeting. Every agent takes lunch at one o'clock, no matter what. So they're out of the office for two hours. They need an hour or so.
我能说这个吗？我说得对吗？你们会同意还是不同意我？演艺圈里的经纪人事情太搞笑了，因为就像你早上第一件事就联系不上你的经纪人，因为他们在开员工会议。每个经纪人都在一点钟吃午饭，不管怎样。所以他们离开办公室两个小时。他们需要一个小时左右。
They need an hour to get there. So they leave at 12. Sorry. We lost him. He's on his way to a lunch. And then he's back at three. Then they do the thing is like, well, he's not in the office. Why not?
他们需要一个小时才能到那里。所以他们在12点离开。抱歉。我们失去他了。他在去吃午饭的路上。然后他在三点回来。然后他们做的事情就像，嗯，他不在办公室。为什么不？
Well, because next week is Thanksgiving. Yeah. Next week is Thanksgiving. Not this week. The fuck are you doing? And then, and then the month of December. And then month of December. Sorry.
嗯，因为下周是感恩节。是的。下周是感恩节。不是这周。你他妈在干什么？然后，然后是十二月。然后是十二月。抱歉。
It's the holidays. Sure. Got it. And then they go, and then, you know, obviously Sundance is at the end of January. So nobody's back till Feb one. It's the most ridiculous racket of all time. We were getting a lot of it. Yeah.
是假期。当然。明白了。然后他们说，然后，你知道，显然圣丹斯电影节在一月底。所以没人会在二月一日之前回来。这是有史以来最荒谬的敲诈。我们经历了很多。是的。
The end of the day goes like this. Well, the end of the day goes, sorry that we're closed. He's going to start rolling calls. And then they call knowing you're not going to pick up. Yeah. Or they call you at seven o'clock and you're having dinner with the kid. And you're like, why are you calling me now? Yeah.
一天结束时是这样的。嗯，一天结束时是，抱歉我们关门了。他要开始轮流打电话了。然后他们打电话，知道你不会接。是的。或者他们在七点钟给你打电话，你正在和孩子吃晚饭。然后你会说，你为什么现在给我打电话？是的。
Sorry. Sorry, Charlie. No, that's it though. We lost sort of patience with that kind of thing. And we said, we're going to leave you guys and we're going to go to a different agency with this. And that sort of prompted them setting a bunch of meetings and, and Rob went around because we thought maybe it'd be too much to have all three of us in the meeting.
抱歉。抱歉，Charlie。不，就是这样。我们对那种事情失去了耐心。我们说，我们要离开你们，我们要带着这个去另一家经纪公司。这促使他们安排了一堆会议，然后Rob四处奔走，因为我们认为如果我们三个人都去开会可能太多了。
So Rob went and, and we had an offer from F. X to shoot a, you know, a real pilot with a real budget. Rob's the closer. He's a closer. He's better in the meeting. He's a better salesman. Now, how are you in meetings? Cause I don't think I'm great in meetings.
所以Rob去了，然后我们收到了FX的提议，去拍一个，你知道，真正的试播集，有真正的预算。Rob是终结者。他是终结者。他在会议上表现更好。他是一个更好的推销员。现在，你在会议上怎么样？因为我不觉得我在会议上很棒。
I don't enjoy them. I feel like I'm trapped in an office. I feel like I'm 45 minutes from getting out of these walls. So it better not go bad in the next minute or two because I'm stuck. Like all those things I start to feel, I start to think about, and then it just, the walls start getting closer and closer like Star Wars. How are you? Do you, do you look at it as like an arena?
我不喜欢它们。我觉得我被困在办公室里了。我觉得我离走出这些墙还有45分钟。所以最好在接下来的一两分钟内不要出问题，因为我被困住了。就像所有那些我开始感觉到的事情，我开始思考，然后它就，墙壁开始像《星球大战》一样越来越近。你怎么样？你把它看作是一个竞技场吗？
Like I'm on stage or this is fun. Like let's win. Or are you looking to get out of there? It's tough. It's a tough part of this business. You know, it depends. They're all very different. You go into a meeting and, and you just, sometimes you just get cold stairs.
就像我在舞台上或者这很有趣。就像让我们赢吧。还是你想从那里出去？这很难。这是这行里很难的一部分。你知道，这取决于。它们都非常不同。你走进一个会议，然后，你有时只会得到冷冰冰的凝视。
Yeah. I do have that vibe sometimes of like, well, here's the idea guys. Do you want to buy it or not? Okay. Yeah. What's the difference? What's it called, Will? It's called sexy.
是的。我有时确实有那种感觉，就像，嗯，这是个主意，伙计们。你们想买还是不想买？好吧。是的。有什么区别？它叫什么，Will？它叫性感。
Sexy. Sexy difference. Yeah. Yeah. Charlie, you know about his sexy indifference, right? Yeah. It's one of, it's one of the major terms. Yeah.
性感。性感差异。是的。是的。Charlie，你知道他的性感冷漠，对吧？是的。这是主要术语之一。是的。
But yeah, it's, you know, it's, it's, you're either selling or you're buying. The buyers usually look at you with absolutely no expression because they can. The sellers, us have to go in there like, you know, circus clowns because we're selling. And that's really what we do in this business. And in a good year, you're selling, you know, you're selling yourself six, seven, eight times and, and winning. Like in other words, you get fired, you know, half a dozen times and rehired half a dozen times if you're killing it.
但是的，你知道，这是，你要么在卖，要么在买。买家通常会毫无表情地看着你，因为他们可以。卖家，我们，必须像，你知道，马戏团小丑一样走进去，因为我们在卖。这确实是我们在这个行业里做的事情。在好的一年里，你在卖，你知道，你在卖你自己六、七、八次，然后，赢了。换句话说，如果你表现出色，你会被解雇，你知道，六次，然后再被雇佣六次。
So, I mean, how many people in, in other industries have to sell themselves or get fired or rehired, maybe three, four times over their whole life? I mean, we got to do that all the time. It's, it's tough. It's, it was hard for me. When you look at the flip of it, Charlie, so you guys, you guys go through this process, you make this thing, you wait, you make this thing, you wait, you're waiting, you have to threaten to leave the agency.
所以，我是说，其他行业里有多少人必须推销自己，或者被解雇或重新雇佣，可能在他们的一生中三、四次？我是说，我们必须一直这样做。这，这很难。这对我来说很难。当你看到它的另一面时，Charlie，所以你们，你们经历了整个过程，你们做了这个东西，你们等，你们做了这个东西，你们等，你们在等待，你们不得不威胁要离开经纪公司。
Finally, FX buys it. You guys are kind of a little bit hat in hand. And now all these years later, you're at the position. We asked you, are you going to do more? Maybe I'll do one more, whatever. Like you have the, the tables have turned a little bit. Yeah. Not a little bit a lot.
最后，FX买了它。你们有点像是在乞求。而现在这么多年过去了，你们处于这个位置。我们问你，你还要做更多吗？也许我会再做一个，随便吧。就像你已经，局势已经稍微扭转了。是的。不是一点点，是很多。
Yeah. I mean, I think the thing is though, when we were shooting that pilot, I was 27 years old. Right. And I'm 46. And so I feel like, you know, I put in my time with this one. It's 23 though. I know it's incredible.
是的。我是说，我想事情是这样的，当我们拍摄那个试播集时，我27岁。对。我46岁。所以我觉得，你知道，我在这上面花时间了。虽然是23年了。我知道这太不可思议了。
Lost age since it started. Yeah, it's incredible. It must be a real stress-free set there. But, but we all make, we all make stuff. We all produce or write or direct or act, whatever. And Charlie, kind of what Jason was talking about, is there a point where you, like, are you getting to a point where it's bothersome that the grind is getting to you about getting all these nodes?
自从它开始以来就失去了年龄。是的，这太不可思议了。那里的片场一定很轻松。但是，但是我们都做，我们都制作或写作或导演或表演，无论什么。Charlie，有点像Jason刚才说的，有没有一个点，你，就像你是否到了一个地步，觉得这种磨练让你感到烦恼，因为要得到所有这些节点？
Because it seems now to put together a package to sell something, you have to really stack the deck high before anybody will even consider you hear about Meryl Streep getting passed or on or whoever these big stars go out to pitch these shows and they get passed. Well, if they get passed and I'm stacking these deck and we're getting nodes, what does it take to keep a production company going? I like to get everything done independently of, of a partner. So, you know, like I'd rather, if I'm going to be pitching a movie, I'd rather have the whole thing written and say, you know, and, and, and a director in place and an actor
因为现在看起来要打包卖东西，你必须在任何人考虑你之前真正把筹码堆得很高，你听说Meryl Streep被拒绝，或者无论这些大明星出去推销这些节目时被拒绝。好吧，如果他们被拒绝，而我正在堆叠这些筹码，我们得到了节点，维持一家制作公司需要什么？我喜欢独立于合作伙伴完成所有事情。所以，你知道，就像如果我要推销一部电影，我宁愿把整个东西写好，然后说，你知道，而且，而且，而且有一位导演到位，还有一位演员
in place and like, here's, we're going. This is what it is. So all they do is write the check. Basically. Yeah. Yeah. You know, as it should be. Yeah.
到位，就像，这是我们要做的。这就是它。所以他们要做的就是写支票。基本上。是的。是的。你知道，本该如此。是的。
But then that means you got to do a bunch of work for free ahead of time, which is cool if you've got the time and the, and the funds to bank on yourself and, and work for free for a little while. Yeah. Look, at some point you're going to have to do that work anyway. So I'm, I'm usually, it depends, right? There's other things I'll pitch and I'll know, okay, I want to get a writer on this and I want to get that person paid.
但这意味着你必须提前做很多免费工作，如果你有时间和资金来押注自己，并且，并且免费工作一段时间，这很酷。是的。看，在某些时候你无论如何都得做那些工作。所以，我，我通常，这取决于，对吧？还有其他我会推销的东西，我会知道，好吧，我想找个编剧来写这个，我想让那个人得到报酬。
So I'll, but even then I'll work with that writer. I'll develop a whole outline. So that movie is basically ready to go and I'll attach a few people to the movie and then I'll go in and be like, here it is. This is what it is. Here's who's acting in it. Here's the director. Now please pay this guy.
所以我，但即使那样我也会和那个编剧合作。我会制定一个完整的提纲。所以那部电影基本上准备好了，我会给电影附加几个人，然后我会进去说，这就是它。这就是它。这是谁在演。这是导演。现在请付钱给这个家伙。
And you got to understand this guy is, he's so fast and he's so good. He wrote horrible bosses too on a five hour plane ride from New York to Los Angeles. I'm not exaggerating. He did a complete rewrite, page one rewrite on it and we used most of it and, and, and out of deference to our writers that, that wrote the draft before I'm exaggerating a little bit and, uh, but Charlie does a great deal of credit for that. Well, I appreciate it. I don't want to take credit away from, from, uh, you know, um, the guys who wound up doing
而且你必须明白这个家伙，他太快了，而且他太好了。他在从纽约到洛杉矶的五小时飞机航程中写了《恶老板2》。我没有夸张。他做了一个完整的重写，第一页重写，我们用了大部分，而且，而且，出于对我们之前写草稿的编剧的尊重，我有点夸张了，呃，但Charlie为此获得了很大的功劳。好吧，我很感激。我不想从，从，呃，你知道，嗯，最终做这件事的人那里抢走功劳
it. I mean, it's just, he's fast, but he is a fast writing. I'm real slow with names. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Wait. So speaking of names. So you and obviously you have a long time relationship with Rob Mackley.
。我是说，这只是，他很快，但他是一个快速写作的人。我对名字真的很慢。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。等等。说到名字。所以你和显然你和Rob Mackley有长期的关系。
How did you guys first meet? What was that? I met Rob on a plane. So we were both being flown out today. We're both being flown out to test for, uh, a pilot for the same role. And it was one of those things where, you know, you're in the airport and you're like, Oh, this guy's got to be an actor. You know, he's got that look.
你们是怎么认识的？那是什么？我在飞机上遇到了Rob。所以我们俩都被飞出去测试，呃，一个试播集的同一个角色。那是那种事情之一，你知道，你在机场，你会说，哦，这家伙一定是个演员。你知道，他有那种样子。
And, uh, the show is called Mather House is about college kids or something like that. And you know, uh, I think, I don't know when I said hello, but maybe after the plane landed and where were you coming from, from New York, from New York? Yeah. We both lived in New York and we're flying out. That, you know, they put you up on, uh, like at the Hilton or something right on, right off the one on one there by universal. Oh yeah.
而且，呃，节目叫Mather House，是关于大学生之类的。而且你知道，呃，我想，我不知道我什么时候打的招呼，但也许在飞机降落后，你从哪里来，从纽约，从纽约？是的。我们都住在纽约，我们要飞出去。那，你知道，他们把你安置在，呃，比如希尔顿酒店或者环球影城旁边的101公路边上的某个地方。哦，是的。
Many times. And then, and then used to find Jason on the side. Yeah. I used to remember pilot season ice to come out there and stay there or the Sheraton or the intercontinental over by Fox, which is where Tony Hale and I stayed for the arrested test. Anyway, keep going. It was my second time that happened.
很多次。然后，然后过去在旁边找Jason。是的。我记得试播季我过去常去那里住，或者住在福克斯旁边的喜来登或洲际酒店，Tony Hale和我就是住在那里参加《发展受阻》的测试。总之，继续。这是我第二次发生这种情况。
It happened to me. I tested for something called weird Henry and they liked me for weird Henry and they flew me out and then they did one sort of, uh, you know, round of notes with the producers and then the studio was like, this show is not going to work and they can the whole thing. And then the same thing happened with Rob. Rob and I both went and tested and I remember thinking like, ah, I got this guy is he doesn't have the charisma. I don't, I'm not worried about him.
发生在我身上了。我测试了一个叫Weird Henry的东西，他们喜欢我演Weird Henry，他们把我飞了过去，然后他们做了一轮，呃，你知道，和制片人的笔记，然后工作室就像，这个节目不会成功，他们取消了整个事情。然后Rob也发生了同样的事情。Rob和我俩都去测试了，我记得当时想，啊，我得到了，这家伙他没有魅力。我不，我不担心他。
Look at his stupid face. Look at his dumb face. Man. This is, he's, he's never going to make it in show business. He'll never own a football team with Ryan Reynolds. Yeah. Forget it. He was too handsome.
看他那愚蠢的脸。看他那笨拙的脸。伙计。这是，他，他永远不会在演艺圈成功。他永远不会和Ryan Reynolds拥有一支足球队。是的。算了吧。他太帅了。
I was like, he's too model-y. You know, you need some, someone real. Uh, and then the same thing happened. They canned the whole show while we were out there and, um, we just kind of bonded and, and stayed buddies and, you know, now I can't get rid of him. You know, every year I'm like, well, maybe, maybe we've done it with the show. He's like, come on, one more. Let's, let's go.
我当时想，他太像模特了。你知道，你需要一些，真正的人。呃，然后同样的事情发生了。他们在我们还在那里的时候就取消了整个节目，而且，嗯，我们只是有点建立了联系，并且，并且保持了好友关系，而且，你知道，现在我甩不掉他了。你知道，每年我都想，嗯，也许，也许我们已经做完这个节目了。他说，来吧，再来一次。让我们，让我们走。
And then, so not only can you not get rid of him always, but then you guys create mythic quest with, uh, it wasn't just the two of you or somebody else too. Yeah. With Megan Gantz. Megan Gantz. Yes. Of course. Yeah.
然后，所以不仅你甩不掉他，而且你们还和，呃，不仅仅是你们俩，还有别人一起创作了《神话任务》。是的。和Megan Gantz。Megan Gantz。是的。当然。是的。
I mean, I'm not even podcasting. I'm just talking about him. I'm like, wait. I hear him. He barely talks about me. I'm talking about this guy constantly. No, no. He talks about you quite a bit.
我是说，我甚至没在做播客。我只是在谈论他。我当时想，等等。我听到了。他几乎不谈论我。我一直在谈论这个家伙。不，不。他谈论你相当多。
We just can't repeat it. Oh, okay. And you guys started a podcast together too. Now you've got this all with Sonny podcast. And now we're talking about the show and people are listening and we're not here to plug that. We're not going to talk about that. No.
我们只是不能重复它。哦，好吧。而且你们也一起开了个播客。现在你们有了这个《费城永远阳光灿烂》的播客。现在我们在谈论这个节目，人们在听，我们不是来宣传那个的。我们不会谈论那个。不。
Let's, let's plug all everything you got. Okay. I think what we should really, if we really want to get this cooking, we should just talk about golf. I mean, let's go. Well, when we were doing horrible bosses and I'm a bit of a golf nut, I would, I would say, oh, Jason, you know, I heard you used to golf and you said, yeah, I don't do it anymore.
让我们，让我们宣传你所有的东西。好吧。我想我们应该真的，如果我们真的想让这个节目火起来，我们应该只谈论高尔夫。我是说，我们走吧。好吧，当我们拍《恶老板》时，我有点高尔夫狂，我会，我会说，哦，Jason，你知道，我听说你以前打高尔夫，你说，是的，我不做了。
I was like, well, you should come out with me, you know, maybe sometime and just, you know, dust off the old sticks and hit a few. You are the most golfing man I know now. It's incredible. It's nonstop. Back then, back then I was very disciplined. I didn't want to dance with the dragon again. You know, I've got addiction issues.
我当时想，好吧，你应该和我一起去，你知道，也许什么时候，只是，你知道，掸掉旧球杆，打几杆。你现在是我认识的最爱打高尔夫的人。这太不可思议了。这是不停的。那时候，那时候我很有纪律。我不想再和龙共舞了。你知道，我有成瘾问题。
Yes. Like no, no, no. You are fully addicted to golf. Dance with the dragon. No, no, no, that's a saying. And then during COVID, you know, Will just threw me a lifeline. He said, listen, buddy, you got to step away from Rachel Maddow, take your PJs off and let's get out there.
是的。就像不，不，不。你完全沉迷于高尔夫。和龙共舞。不，不，不，那是个说法。然后在那期间，你知道，Will只是给了我一根救命稻草。他说，听着，伙计，你得远离Rachel Maddow，脱掉你的睡衣，让我们出去。
Do something socially distant. Let's, let's play golf. And two weeks later, we were in Pebble Beach. Yeah. No joke. You put it right in my arm. Yeah. I love it.
做点社交距离的事情。让我们，让我们打高尔夫。两周后，我们在圆石滩。是的。不开玩笑。你把它直接放进我的手臂里。是的。我喜欢它。
Well, I love that you do it. I hope you don't give it up. No, no, I don't. Look at me. I'm dressed. Look at my outfit for Christ's sake. I'm a half hour from the tee. Oh, keep it snappy because I know you got a tee today.
好吧，我喜欢你这样做。我希望你不要放弃。不，不，我没有。看看我。我穿好了。看看我的衣服，看在上帝的份上。我离发球台还有半小时。哦，快点，因为我知道你今天有球局。
Yeah, let's go. Charlie, I have a shot. I know, I know your question is going to be, Hey, Charlie, how, how long and straight are you off the tee? Very. He's very consistent off the tee. It's unbelievable. This guy's a single digit handicap listeners.
是的，我们走吧。Charlie，我有机会。我知道，我知道你的问题会是，嘿，Charlie，你发球台上的距离和直线度怎么样？非常。他在发球台上非常稳定。这太不可思议了。这家伙是单差点听众。
Anybody who's into golf, this guy, it, this guy doesn't shoot over 80. Okay. It's, he's a natural athlete. He played a lot of baseball when he was coming up. This is the most you know about me. This is surprising. Wait. So, so Charlie, speaking of growing up, so, so I mentioned in the thing that you play
任何喜欢高尔夫的人，这家伙，它，这家伙打球不超过80杆。好吧。它，他是个天生的运动员。他成长过程中打了很多棒球。这是你对我了解最多的。这令人惊讶。等等。所以，所以Charlie，说到成长，所以，所以我提到你弹
piano and you play all these instruments, what's up with that? So, because I don't know where to look at Sean perked up. Sean doesn't want to talk about a long off the tee, but oh, let's get that harmonica in his mouth. Let's do it. Let's do it. I probably have one lying around. Uh, I don't know where the violin thing came like, I was, thank you God, but you
钢琴，你弹奏所有这些乐器，这是怎么回事？所以，因为我不知道该看哪里，Sean振作起来了。Sean不想谈论发球台上的距离，但哦，让我们把那个口琴放进他嘴里。让我们做吧。让我们做吧。我可能随手有一个。呃，我不知道小提琴的事情是怎么来的，就像，我，感谢上帝，但你
have that ready to go. Yeah. Anytime there's a bad joke. Hey, where's that keyboard we're going to introduce this year, Sean? Yeah. We're going to, I know I'm too lazy to lift this up and go in there because I got to hook it all up, but wait, Charlie, do you still play violin, do you still play these instruments?
有那个准备好了。是的。任何时候有烂笑话。嘿，Sean，我们今年要介绍的那个键盘在哪里？是的。我们要，我知道我太懒了，不想把它拿起来进去，因为我得把所有东西都接上，但等等，Charlie，你还拉小提琴吗，你还弹这些乐器吗？
Do you do that? No, I never play, I never played the violin. That's one of those. Oh, that was not true. No, I think I played the violin from like three to three in one month, you know, where my parents were like, well, this is too young. The piano is very accurate. Yeah.
你做那个吗？不，我从来不，我从来没拉过小提琴。那是其中之一。哦，那不是真的。不，我想我拉小提琴大概是从三岁到三岁一个月，你知道，我父母当时想，嗯，这太小了。钢琴非常准确。是的。
Is there an instrument that you excel at or that you stick with? Keep it clean. I don't excel at any of them, but I, I, I can play a little piano and a little guitar and that's, you know, I can, I can write like a goofy song that we put on sunny, but I'm done. Was that something that your parents like incurred? Like, did you take piano lessons, guitar lessons, all that kind of thing? Yes.
有没有你擅长或者你坚持的乐器？保持干净。我不擅长其中任何一个，但我，我，我能弹一点钢琴和一点吉他，那就是，你知道，我能，我能写一首我们在《费城永远阳光灿烂》里放的傻歌，但我完了。那是你父母鼓励的吗？就像，你上过钢琴课，吉他课，所有那种事情吗？是的。
I took piano lessons maybe till I was 10 and then I switched to the trombone. I used to have a little sweatshirt because I was in the school band that said Charlie Trombone. So that like became my nickname for too long. You know the problem with the trombone is if you leave it in the rain, it gets rusty, you know? I will. It's true.
我上钢琴课大概到10岁，然后我换成了长号。我以前有一件小运动衫，因为我在学校乐队里，上面写着Charlie Trombone。所以那就像成了我的绰号太久了。你知道长号的问题是如果你把它留在雨里，它会生锈，你知道？我会的。这是真的。
It's true. If you leave it in the rain, clean it up. Clean it out. Well, you keep it clean. You get some kind of brass cleaner or something like that. You keep it clean. Charlie, when you, when you write and produce or direct or whatever you do, do you think about music when you're doing it?
这是真的。如果你把它留在雨里，清理干净。清理出来。好吧，你保持它干净。你弄点铜器清洁剂之类的东西。你保持它干净。Charlie，当你，当你写作和制作或导演或无论你做什么时，你在做的时候会想到音乐吗？
Or is it an afterthought? Yeah. It's a big part of how I write something. I'll be just listening to, you know, a style of music and I'll have an idea. The Peshmode. Yeah. I'll be listening to the Peshmode and I'll be thinking, I got to do a movie with Bateman where he, you know, wears eye shadow and trench coats.
还是事后才想到的？是的。这是我写东西方式的很大一部分。我只是会听，你知道，一种音乐风格，然后我就会有一个想法。Depeche Mode。是的。我会听Depeche Mode，我会想，我得和Bateman拍一部电影，他，你知道，画眼影，穿风衣。
Yeah. You should see me. I got great goth skills. Yeah. Yeah. I do love, I do love to Peshmode. Wait, Charlie, I know so little about, so it says that you were born in, in New York, in the city.
是的。你应该看看我。我有很棒的哥特技巧。是的。是的，我确实喜欢Depeche Mode。等等，Charlie，我对，所以它说你出生在，在纽约，在城里。
Yeah. True story? True story. Cause my parents, my parents both met at Columbia, where they were both music, getting their doctorates in musicology and then they were... Wait a second. Wait a second. Pump the brass.
是的。真实故事？真实故事。因为我父母，我父母都在哥伦比亚大学相遇，他们都在那里学习音乐，获得音乐学博士学位，然后他们是……等等。等等。泵一下铜管。
Wow. So your parents, so you kind of blow, brush through the whole music thing and your own involvement with me, your parents have degrees in music from Columbia? Yeah. Yeah. My parents are very... Smart. Smart.
哇。所以你父母，所以你有点吹嘘，略过了整个音乐事情和你自己对我的参与，你父母有哥伦比亚大学的音乐学位？是的。是的。我父母非常……聪明。聪明。
As is my sister. She also has her PhD in musicology. What? And what happened here was that, you know, I'm an idiot and I was like, I got to get away from this music thing. So, you know, I'm taking trombone lessons and all my buddies are outside playing baseball and I eventually, you know, walked away from it all and gave it up. But then when I got to like, maybe a senior in high school or college, I picked up the
正如我姐姐一样。她也有她的音乐学博士学位。什么？这里发生的事情是，你知道，我是个白痴，我当时想，我得远离这个音乐事情。所以，你知道，我上长号课，我所有的伙伴都在外面打棒球，我最终，你知道，远离了这一切，放弃了它。但后来当我到了，大概高中或大学高年级时，我拿起了
guitar and I was like, oh, this is maybe, could be cool or a way to meet a girl. And then I got back into it. But I didn't want to be, they had no money and I didn't want to, I didn't want to be a music person. So you became an actor. So they're at Columbia. They're both taking, they're both in programs, music programs at Columbia. They meet, you're born in the city and then what happens?
吉他，我当时想，哦，这也许，可能很酷，或者是一种认识女孩的方式。然后我又回到了它。但我不想成为，他们没钱，我不想，我不想成为一个音乐人。所以你成了演员。所以他们在哥伦比亚大学。他们都在上课，他们都在哥伦比亚大学的音乐项目里。他们相遇，你出生在城里，然后发生了什么？
How long did you live there? How long? And then my dad got a job at a college in Rhode Island and my mother's family was from Rhode Island way back, way, way back and they went and never left. They're still there. And so you grew up in Rhode Island. I grew up in Rhode Island. Yeah.
你在那里住了多久？多久？然后我爸爸在罗德岛的一所大学找到了一份工作，我母亲的家人很久很久以前就来自罗德岛，他们去了就再也没离开。他们还在那里。所以你在罗德岛长大。我在罗德岛长大。是的。
Yeah. How did the acting thing hit you? Was it like a high school drama thing? That's a good question. I mean, I did plays like a, like in third and fourth grade and always enjoyed it. And then I wanted to do the school plays in high school, but I was kind of too nervous to join the group. I thought, ah, I don't, I don't, I don't.
是的。演戏的事情是怎么打动你的？是像高中戏剧那样吗？这是一个好问题。我是说，我演过戏，像，在三年级和四年级，一直很喜欢它。然后我想在高中参加学校戏剧，但我有点太紧张了，不敢加入那个团体。我想，啊，我不，我不，我不。
But with the musical background, wouldn't you think that you can combine the plays and the music and do what, what we call that, the theater that's, but there's got, there's a music based theater out there. I'm not quite sure. I don't think there's a term for it yet. What would be an example of something that you might do on music? Five, six, seven, eight. Go.
但有了音乐背景，你不觉得你可以把戏剧和音乐结合起来，做我们称之为那个，戏剧，那是，但有，有一个基于音乐的戏剧在那里。我不太确定。我不认为它现在有一个术语。你会做的一个例子是什么，关于音乐？五，六，七，八。走。
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da. Ba-da-da-da-da. You guys are going to have to take that slide with us a little way. I mean, Charlie. So then Charlie, so then you finish high school and you say, um, I'm going to go to New York City and I'm going to try to become a professional guitar player or actor. Yes. I did have that thought.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da。Ba-da-da-da-da。你们得和我们一起走那段滑梯。我是说，Charlie。所以然后Charlie，所以然后你高中毕业，你说，嗯，我要去纽约市，我要尝试成为一名职业吉他手或演员。是的。我确实有那个想法。
I was like, well, do it. Which one? I didn't know. I was like, maybe I want to write music or maybe I want to do, uh, acting. But you knew your future wasn't in Rhode Island. It was probably in Manhattan. Yeah. Well, first I went to college, Jason.
我当时想，嗯，做吧。哪一个？我不知道。我当时想，也许我想写音乐，或者也许我想做，呃，表演。但你知道你的未来不在罗德岛。它可能在曼哈顿。是的。首先我上了大学，Jason。
Where was that? Wait, hang on. What's college? Yeah. It's a school after the studio school. Voluntary additional school? I don't understand it. Voluntary.
那是哪里？等等，等等。什么是大学？是的。那是工作室学校之后的一所学校。自愿附加学校？我不明白。自愿。
Yeah. That's the part I couldn't compute when I was a kid. What trailer was that in on the mortar lot? Yeah. One with a flat tire. And here's what happened. I went to the voluntary additional school and they had a theater program, but they also had a baseball team and I didn't make baseball team and I thought, oh, well, I'll go join
是的。那是我小时候无法计算的部分。那是在砂浆地段的哪个拖车里？是的。一个轮胎瘪了的。这就是发生的事情。我去了自愿附加学校，他们有一个戏剧项目，但他们也有一个棒球队，我没进棒球队，我想，哦，好吧，我去加入
the theater club. And then I just got hooked. I was like, I like doing the plays and it seems to- Was this school in New York? This school was in Northern Massachusetts called Merrimack College and you could get in if you had a pulse and they let me in. My favorite thing in the world is swapping horrible theater stories. Did I tell you guys about the wheelchair story?
戏剧俱乐部。然后我就迷上了。我当时想，我喜欢演戏，而且它似乎——这所学校在纽约吗？这所学校在马萨诸塞州北部，叫梅里马克学院，如果你有脉搏就能进去，他们让我进去了。我世界上最喜欢的事情就是交换糟糕的戏剧故事。我告诉过你们轮椅的故事吗？
Yeah. No, let's go. Let's go. Okay, so- Let's just pull the interview over to the side. Hang on. No, really quick. This is horror.
是的。不，我们走吧。我们走吧。好吧，所以——让我们把采访拉到一边。等等。不，很快。这是恐怖。
I was at sophomore in high school and I was in charge of changing the scenery, right? The battens that would lift the scenery. So in between, we had like, we were doing one act. So in between each act, we had like, you know, 15, 30 seconds to change the big, huge scenery and pull them up. And I was in charge of all those hydraulics. So the stage manager points at me, she's like, go, and I didn't realize there was a rope hanging on the side that somehow hooked onto the wheelchair that the guy needed in the
我是高中二年级，我负责更换布景，对吧？提升布景的板条。所以中间，我们有像，我们在演一幕剧。所以每一幕之间，我们有像，你知道，15，30秒来更换巨大，巨大的布景并把它们拉起来。我负责所有那些液压系统。所以舞台经理指着我，她就像，走，我没意识到旁边挂着一根绳子，不知怎么地钩住了那个家伙在
next scene. This isn't over from a cartoon I saw. No, I swear to God, this happened. And I raised it and the hook pulled the wheelchair up. So the curtain goes up and the wheelchair is just swinging, hanging in midair. Oh, shit. And the guy's first line was, you know, sending like, I don't know if I'll ever walk again. But he had to, it was, it was awful.
下一幕需要的轮椅。这不是我看到的卡通片里的吗？不，我向上帝发誓，这发生了。我把它升起来，钩子把轮椅拉了起来。所以幕布升起，轮椅就在那里摇摆，悬在半空中。哦，该死。那个家伙的第一句台词是，你知道，发送像，我不知道我是否还能再走路。但他不得不，它，它太糟糕了。
Oh, golly. To smart list. Hey, Charlie, so, so you up there, so you, you, you come down out of the junior college and you come to, to, to New York city and you don't just knock on a door and say, I'm here. I'd like to be an actor. What do you, do you look in the paper for auditions or an agent or what was your first step?
哦，天哪。到Smart List。嘿，Charlie，所以，所以你在那里，所以你，你，你从初级学院下来，你来到，到，到纽约市，你不仅仅是敲门说，我在这里。我想成为一名演员。你做什么，你是在报纸上找试镜还是经纪人，或者你的第一步是什么？
Yeah. I did all that crap. You know, you get the village voice and you're looking through all those things. I had a really lucky break when I was in college. There was, there was a guy there named John Fussman and he was like one of those guys who was like 35 and in college and just hanging out just outside the school grounds, basically the fence. Yeah.
是啊。我做过所有那些烂事。你知道，你会买《乡村之声》，然后翻看上面的所有信息。我在大学时运气特别好。当时有个叫约翰·福斯曼的人，他大概35岁，还在上大学，整天就在学校外面晃悠，基本上就在围栏边上。是啊。
And he had tipped me off to a place called the Williams town theater festival. And I, I went there to sort of, you know, empty garbage cans and, and maybe say one line in a play and just intern and they had like a program where you could audition and, and be part of a non-equity group. And after my first summer there, I was still in college. The next year I auditioned and I got to be part of that group. And a bunch of agents go up there. You're right.
他向我透露了一个叫威廉斯敦戏剧节的地方。我去了那里，你知道，就是去倒垃圾，在戏里说一句台词，当个实习生。他们有个项目，你可以去试镜，成为非工会团体的一员。我在那儿度过第一个夏天后，还在上大学。第二年我试镜成功，加入了那个团体。很多经纪人会去那里。你说得对。
Yeah. After my third year there, I got an agent, but Sean, did you ever do that? I'd love to do Williamstown. Did you ever do that? I would love to know, but I would love to, but you know, Charlie was going to ask you like there, there's, when, when we were all young, all four of us and other people like us that are actors, there was a definite path to what you wanted, right? You got your headshots and then you had your resume on the back and then you would submit
是啊。在那儿待了三年后，我签了经纪人。但肖恩，你做过那种事吗？我很想去威廉斯敦。你做过吗？我很想知道，但我很想……你知道，查理，我本来想问你，当我们都还年轻的时候，我们四个以及其他像我们一样的演员，对于想要的东西都有明确的路径，对吧？你准备好头像照，背面印上简历，然后投递给
them to agents and then agents was, but now it seems so different. Do you have friends like, does your sister have friends and be like, Hey, Charlie, can you help my friend out? They want to get into the biz and they need advice. I mean, do you ever get people coming to you and what would that advice be now for kids rather than when we were growing up? Weirdly, I don't get too much of that. I don't know if I don't give off a vibe of that.
经纪人，然后经纪人就……但现在看起来完全不同了。你有朋友吗？你妹妹有朋友会说：“嘿，查理，你能帮帮我朋友吗？他们想进这行，需要建议。”我的意思是，有没有人来找你？对于现在的孩子来说，这些建议和我们成长时会有什么不同？奇怪的是，我没怎么遇到过这种情况。我不知道是不是我没散发出那种氛围。
I'll help her. I'm not sure why, but do you feel, no, but let me rephrase that. Do you feel shitty about yourself that nobody wants acting tips from you or career advice? I had that. Sean, you know, when I was a kid, this is true story, when I was living in New York and I was at my, I didn't know anybody in New York and somehow my mom knew through so many from like Winnipeg knew the actor Len Karyu, do you know that guy? Sure.
我会帮她的。我不确定为什么，但你觉得……不，让我换个说法。没人想从你这儿得到表演技巧或职业建议，你对自己感到糟糕吗？我有过那种经历。肖恩，你知道，我小时候，这是真事，我住在纽约，我当时……我在纽约谁也不认识，不知怎么的，我妈通过温尼伯的一个人认识了演员莱恩·卡里奥，你认识那个人吗？当然。
Len Karyu. And so somehow she's like, you should call and I was like, okay. So I called him poor guy because now I sort of 30 years later, I get that flip, which is like, he's like, Hey, what, what can I do for you? I'm like, well, I'm just in New York and I'm going to theater school and like, okay. I'm ready to be successful. Yeah. And like, I get now that position, I even felt it at the time where he's like, I don't
莱恩·卡里奥。不知怎么的，她说你应该打个电话，我说好吧。所以我打给了他，可怜的家伙，因为现在30年后，我理解那种反转了，就是他会说：“嘿，我能为你做什么？”我说：“嗯，我刚到纽约，正在上戏剧学校，我想……好吧，我准备好成功了。”是啊。我现在理解那种处境了，当时我就感觉到了，他心里想的是：“我
know what you want me to do for you, buddy, but you know, I've already, I'm worried about my own day to day over here. And so you do get those calls sometimes from friends of friends and they go, Hey, our kid is 18 and he's moving to New York and can you call him and give him, give him some advice? And there's really nothing you can say to anybody. I actually like it. I actually don't mind it. Yeah.
不知道你想让我为你做什么，伙计，但我已经……我还在担心我自己的日常琐事呢。”所以你确实会偶尔接到朋友的朋友打来的电话，他们说：“嘿，我们的孩子18岁了，要搬到纽约去，你能给他打个电话，给他一些建议吗？”其实你真的没什么可对别人说的。我其实挺喜欢的。我其实不介意。是啊。
It's all about timing, but yeah, I actually, actually, what do you tell people, you know, because you're getting an agent, like you do have to get into kind of a showcase situation. It's just really tough for everybody. I think you have to create your own path, you know, gone are the days of relying and waiting on phone calls and agents and all that to do it for you. You have to pick up a camera. You have to write the thing, direct the thing, act the thing, put it on YouTube, all that kind of stuff and Instagram and so that's how, because every Instagram star wants to
这全看时机，但确实，其实，你告诉人们什么呢？因为你要找经纪人，你确实得进入那种展示的场合。这对每个人来说都真的很难。我认为你必须开辟自己的道路，你知道，那种依赖并等待电话、经纪人来为你做一切的时代已经过去了。你必须拿起摄像机。你必须写剧本、导演、表演，把它放到YouTube上，还有Instagram之类的东西，因为每个Instagram明星都想
be an actor and every actor wants to be like have the most followers. You guys were kind of like the first people to really do that in a way that has been not just successful, but also had longevity. You guys created your own stuff. That was not the norm before you guys did that. No, that's true. Yeah. Although, you know, in some ways, doesn't everybody do that?
成为演员，每个演员都想拥有最多的粉丝。你们算是第一批真正做到这一点的人，不仅成功了，而且还保持了长久。你们创造了自己的东西。在你们做这件事之前，这并不是常态。不，那是真的。是啊。虽然，你知道，在某些方面，难道不是每个人都这样做吗？
Like somebody, I guess the lonely Island guys did that too. Yeah. Like, well, but they were already part of an infrastructure there at Saturday Night Live. No, no, no, no, before those guys made videos and stuff. And they did. Andy Samberg. Andy and Akiva and Jorm did, yeah, they made some videos on Lonely Island and they made a pilot called Awesome Town that Phil and Chris, Phil Lord and Chris Miller produced.
就像有人，我想孤独岛乐队的那些人也做了。是啊。就像，嗯，但他们已经是《周六夜现场》基础设施的一部分了。不，不，不，在那些人制作视频之前。他们确实做了。安迪·萨姆伯格。安迪、阿基瓦和乔姆做了，是啊，他们在“孤独岛”上制作了一些视频，他们还制作了一个叫《Awesome Town》的试播集，菲尔和克里斯，菲尔·洛德和克里斯·米勒制作的。
If you've ever seen that, it's really, it's really rad. But they did the same thing, which was, but again, that was around the same time that Sonny started. It was back in that. What was unique about what we did is we did it for television where, you know, like you, there was a lot of that in independent film, if you're the Cohen brothers, you know, you raise money, you do blood sample, and then you, you know, you go do Raising Arizona, whatever it is.
如果你看过那个，真的很棒。但他们做了同样的事情，不过，那也是在《费城永远阳光灿烂》开始的同一时期。是在那个时候。我们所做的事情的独特之处在于，我们是为电视做的，你知道，就像你一样，独立电影里有很多这种情况，如果你是科恩兄弟，你知道，你筹集资金，拍《血迷宫》，然后，你知道，你去拍《抚养亚利桑那》，不管是什么。
And we, I guess we just took that model to television and we said, well, we'll, you know, we'll do the first one real cheap and down dirty. And then hopefully someone gives us money to do this more legitimately. But going back to your question before, I often do promote Williamstown, which for me was like a showcase situation. Or if you're really serious about acting, go to grad school, which I'd wish I'd done. But because that place was, was not only boot camp for acting, it was boot camp for you better show up and shine.
我想我们只是把那个模式带到了电视上，我们说，好吧，我们会，你知道，我们会把第一部拍得非常便宜且粗糙。然后希望有人给我们钱，让我们更正规地做这件事。但回到你之前的问题，我经常推荐威廉斯敦，对我来说，那就像是一个展示的场合。或者如果你真的想认真演戏，就去读研究生，我真希望我当时读了。因为那个地方，不仅是表演的新兵训练营，也是让你必须表现并闪耀的新兵训练营。
Because in that group, in that non-equity group, it was myself and Catherine Hahn and Sterling Brown. Wow. And I mean, the competition was so fierce and, and Jimmy Simpson and these people were going to outshine you and not, they weren't trying to outshine you, but they were going to do their work and they were going to be, you know, they were going to come to rehearsal and not set and just blow it out of the water. So you had to learn how to, I feel like my first summer there, I did well in some plays
因为在那个团体里，在那个非工会团体里，有我和凯瑟琳·哈恩，还有斯特林·布朗。哇。我的意思是，竞争太激烈了，吉米·辛普森这些人会盖过你的风头，不是说他们想盖过你，而是他们会做好他们的工作，他们会，你知道，他们会来排练，而不是坐在那儿，直接把表演发挥得淋漓尽致。所以你必须学会如何……我觉得我在那儿的第一个夏天，我在一些戏里表现得不错，
and I thought the next year I thought everyone would be like, well, he's the man. Let's give him everything. And it wasn't that way. You know, it was a rude awakening of like, well, you did that. What are you going to do now? So that was such a good boot camp in terms of like, do your work, work hard, make sure you make sure you're not wasting anybody's time. It's funny you say that I remember having one of my acting teachers years ago, he was
我以为第二年每个人都会觉得，好吧，他是最棒的。让我们给他一切。但事实并非如此。你知道，这是一种当头棒喝，就像是，好吧，你做到了，现在你打算做什么？所以那是一个非常好的新兵训练营，关于如何做好你的工作，努力工作，确保你没有浪费任何人的时间。你说得很有趣，我记得我多年前的一位表演老师，他说
saying like, look, all the process you do, all the work you do, whatever, when you show up on set, no, they don't give a shit. You got to deliver in the moment and that's it. And that was the only sort of piece of advice that I've ever given young people, which is just like, you got to, you got to be on top of your shit. You got to know your shit. Like you said, you got to be ready to deliver in the moment because that's what matters. Yeah.
就像，看，你做的所有过程，你做的所有工作，无论怎样，当你出现在片场时，不，他们不在乎。你必须在当下交付成果，就是这样。这是我给年轻人唯一的建议，就是你必须，你必须掌控好你的事情。你必须了解你的事情。就像你说的，你必须准备好在当下交付成果，因为那才是最重要的。是啊。
It's a bit exhausting, right? You do. Sure. You just work into this. Years go by, you develop whatever fame, success, and you kind of think, okay, well now I can coast, but you know, the phone doesn't really ring. Maybe it does for DiCaprio, but for nobody else, like you have to like, you got to put something together and you have to, and then when you, when you are in it, you can't stink,
这有点让人精疲力竭，对吧？确实。你只是投入其中。岁月流逝，你获得了某种名声、成功，你可能会想，好吧，现在我可以轻松一下了，但你知道，电话并没有真正响起来。也许迪卡普里奥会响，但对其他人来说，你必须，你必须把一些东西拼凑起来，然后当你，当你身处其中时，你不能表现得很烂，
right? You got to, you got to shine. Your son, is he too young to know that he wants to do what dad does or? Yeah, where mom does too. Both of you guys are actors. Yeah. He has a great part in Paul Thomas Anderson's film right now. Oh, she's great at it.
对吧？你必须，你必须闪耀。你的儿子，他太小了，不知道他想做他爸爸做的事吗？是啊。妈妈做的也是。你们俩都是演员。是啊。他现在在保罗·托马斯·安德森的电影里有一个很棒的角色。哦，她演得很好。
That movie is amazing. Yeah, it is. That guy. Paul Thomas Anderson? Yeah. Talk about a guy. I think things are going to work out for him, I think. He's going to make it.
那部电影太棒了。是啊，确实。那个人。保罗·托马斯·安德森？是啊。说起那个人。我想事情会对他有利的，我想。他会成功的。
He is going to make it. Paul Thomas Anderson is the greatest director of all time and go, and ignite, and ignite. Right. How about he's my favorite for sure. I know, me too. He's the greatest. I got to go see a screening of that movie at his house, which, you know, he has these, maybe he doesn't want me to tell, but he has like these film projectors.
他会成功的。保罗·托马斯·安德森是有史以来最伟大的导演，去吧，点燃，点燃。对吧？他绝对是我的最爱。我知道，我也是。他是最伟大的。我有幸在他家看了那部电影的放映，你知道，他有这些，也许他不想让我说，但他有这些电影放映机。
He's got like this barn that he's converted into like a screening room. And for Tracy, the name of the movie is? Licorice Pizza. Licorice Pizza. Yeah. Licorice Pizza, which is a name of a record store that was all over the valley when I was growing up. Right.
他有个谷仓，被他改造成了放映室。对于特蕾西，电影的名字是？《甘草披萨》。《甘草披萨》。是啊。《甘草披萨》，这是我成长过程中山谷里到处都是的一家唱片店的名字。对吧。
Anyway, so he's got this cool. That's why you're crying, and your wife, Amy, Mary Elizabeth Ellis, whom I know, she and I did a pilot together years ago, as you know, and she's a tremendously talented actor, and she's in Paul Thomas Anderson's movie, Licorice Pizza. So you went to a screening at his house. Screening burn. Yeah, just to kind of, and then to get to hang out with Maya Rudolph. So that was a, I just didn't want to blow it for my wife.
总之，他有这个很酷的。这就是你哭的原因，还有你的妻子，艾米·玛丽·伊丽莎白·埃利斯，我认识她，正如你所知，她和我多年前一起拍过一个试播集，她是一位非常有才华的演员，她在保罗·托马斯·安德森的电影《甘草披萨》里。所以你去他家参加了放映会。放映谷仓。是啊，只是为了，然后能和玛雅·鲁道夫待在一起。所以我只是不想搞砸我妻子的事。
I'm like, just keep cool, man, and don't, don't, don't get drunk and don't act dumb. Did you stand up with a bunch of notes at the end of it? I had a couple of notes, but he wasn't listening, you know? That's the problem with these artists. Yeah, we were, we were locked. Pop Charlie Day is for a couple scenes. That's really going to make this movie pop. We'll be right back.
我心想，保持冷静，伙计，别，别喝醉，别表现得像个傻瓜。最后你有没有站起来提一堆意见？我有几个意见，但他没听，你知道？这就是这些艺术家的毛病。是啊，我们被锁定了。查理·戴客串几个场景。那真的会让这部电影火起来。我们马上回来。
All right. Back to the show. Now listen, Charlie, for your new podcast, which is, I think it's becoming really popular, isn't it? Yes, it is. Do you guys have, have guests on or is it just you three chatting? Right now it's just us chatting. I mean, that kind of caught us off guard, you know?
好了。回到节目。现在听着，查理，关于你的新播客，我想它正变得非常受欢迎，不是吗？是的，确实。你们有嘉宾吗，还是只有你们三个在聊天？目前只是我们自己在聊天。我的意思是，那让我们措手不及，你知道？
This was my gripe with Macklehenny. About two years ago, I was like, we should do a sunny podcast. We should just talk about the show. The fans probably want to hear that. And he's like, oh, everybody's doing podcasts, you know, like, you know, we're too late. Then this year he shows up, he goes, you know what we should do? A sunny podcast. Oh boy.
这是我对麦克尔亨尼的抱怨。大约两年前，我说，我们应该做一个《阳光》播客。我们应该只谈论这部剧。粉丝们可能想听那个。他说，哦，每个人都在做播客，你知道，我们太晚了。然后今年他出现了，他说，你知道我们应该做什么吗？一个《阳光》播客。哦，天哪。
I'm like this motherfucker. I'm like. Yeah, I know this guy. But here's the difference. And here's why I've benefited so greatly from a partnership with Rob. When I said it, it was just gobbledygook talk. And when he said it, he already had the mics and the producer lined up and ready to go. He's an action.
我心想这个混蛋。我心想。是啊，我了解这家伙。但区别在于，这就是为什么我从与罗布的合作中受益匪浅。当我说的时候，那只是胡言乱语。而当他说的时候，他已经准备好了麦克风和制片人，准备出发了。他是个行动派。
He's an action. He's an action guy. So it's been good for me to unite with an action guy. Being on that side of it, do you, and we all know this as actors promoting and, and, and marketing and all that stuff, having to do talk shows and whatever podcasts or whatever the thing is, do you have a preference of being a guest or a host? Well, I guess we're not really hosting anyone. So I don't know.
他是个行动派。他是个行动派。所以与一个行动派联合对我来说很好。身处那一面，你，我们作为演员都知道这一点，推广、营销等等，不得不参加脱口秀节目，无论是什么播客，你更喜欢做嘉宾还是主持人？嗯，我想我们并没有真正主持任何人。所以我不知道。
I don't know. Yeah. I mean, you're kind of hosting a podcast, but yeah, we're really just kind of shooting a shit. Okay. People seem to want to listen to it. But you're, I think that one of the things that we're all talking about the same thing we obviously have, there are a lot of similarities, which is you talk about, we create our own
我不知道。是啊。我的意思是，你有点像在主持一个播客，但确实，我们真的只是在闲聊。好吧。人们似乎想听。但你，我认为我们都在谈论同一件事，我们显然有很多相似之处，就是你谈到的，我们创造自己的
weather, we do our own thing and we do a lot of different things. You've got to, you're doing a podcast, you do your show, you've got this new movie on Amazon, which was, that was a sexy segue. That was a good segue. Yeah. I did a romcom finally. So you did a romcom. Yeah.
天气，我们做自己的事情，我们做很多不同的事情。你必须，你在做播客，你在做你的节目，你在亚马逊上有这部新电影，那是一个性感的过渡。那是一个很好的过渡。是啊。我终于拍了一部浪漫喜剧。所以你拍了一部浪漫喜剧。是啊。
Saw me as rom. So, so talk a little bit about, cause I want to get into, you do, do a lot of different stuff and you've got a lot of different gears, which is commendable and you're obviously, you know, you're a talented guy. So you go and you do a romcom. What was the, were you just like, yeah, fucking, I could do a romcom. I was always dying to do a romcom cause I actually really enjoy them. And I sort of wanted to have my, you know, Tom Hanks moment or Billy Crystal or whatever.
把我当成浪漫。所以，谈谈吧，因为我想深入了解，你确实做了很多不同的事情，你有很多不同的档次，这是值得称赞的，你显然，你知道，你是个有才华的人。所以你去拍了一部浪漫喜剧。当时是，你只是觉得，是的，他妈的，我能拍一部浪漫喜剧。我一直渴望拍一部浪漫喜剧，因为我真的很喜欢它们。我有点想拥有我的，你知道，汤姆·汉克斯时刻，或者比利·克里斯托，或者其他什么。
And was there a sex scene? No, there's, there's, you know, is there a kiss? Hey, cool. Hey, take it easy, man. What are you imagining? Jason, what are you imagining? Talk to what you're imagining. Well, because some people can go their whole careers or a large portion of it without
有性爱场景吗？不，有，有，你知道，有吻戏吗？嘿，酷。嘿，放轻松，伙计。你在想象什么？杰森，你在想象什么？说说你在想象什么。嗯，因为有些人可能整个职业生涯或很大一部分时间都没有
ever doing a sex scene. And then all of a sudden the day shows up and it's like, oh my God, I've been in this business 30 years and I've never had to like fake love-making. Did you have to do that? No, that's a good question. No, I have. Have you ever had to do that? Yeah.
拍过性爱场景。然后突然有一天，就像，哦天哪，我在这行干了30年，从来没不得不假装做爱。你不得不那样做吗？不，这是个好问题。不，我有。你曾经不得不那样做吗？是啊。
I have a, I have a very graphic one on It's Always Sunny where we did a ski episode and we were making sort of fun of like 80s ski movies and over the top sex scenes. So, you know, I was like, it was fine, you know, like, you don't have to ask him in a whisper wheel. I was just saying walk us through it. I mean, you know, it's always the case with me with sex scenes. I'm always, I always feel bad for the other person, you know, where I'm like, hey, look, I'm sorry.
我在《费城永远阳光灿烂》里有一个非常露骨的场景，我们拍了一集滑雪的，我们有点在嘲笑80年代的滑雪电影和夸张的性爱场景。所以，你知道，我当时想，这没关系，你知道，你不需要低声问他。我只是说带我们过一遍。我的意思是，你知道，对我来说，性爱场景总是这样。我总是，我总是为另一个人感到难过，你知道，我心想，嘿，听着，我很抱歉。
It's just me and this, you know, I'm pasty and- Sean, you had to do one? Yeah. There was this cult show, which is fantastic called Campus Ladies with Carrie Aisley and Kristen Sussin and Will Forte was on it and a bunch of funny people were on it. And Jonah Hill. That was Jonah Hill's first show. And I played somebody who wasn't the brightest, who always wore a backpack.
这只是我和这个，你知道，我很苍白，而且——肖恩，你不得不拍一个？是啊。有一个邪典剧，非常棒，叫《校园女士》，有凯莉·艾斯利和克里斯汀·苏森，威尔·福特也在里面，还有一堆有趣的人。还有乔纳·希尔。那是乔纳·希尔的第一部剧。我扮演了一个不太聪明的人，总是背着背包。
How'd you get into that character? Wow. Well, so I just put a backpack on and then I had to wear no clothes, accept the backpack and have sex with and literally have intercourse with Kristen Sussin. Oh. Oh, okay. How did that go? Jason?
你是怎么进入那个角色的？哇。嗯，所以我只是背上背包，然后我不得不不穿衣服，除了背包，并与克里斯汀·苏森发生性关系，字面意思上的性交。哦。哦，好吧。那进展如何？杰森？
Fine. Oh, sorry. Go ahead. Sean, finish on. That was it. That was it. And Jason, what about your sex stuff? I've got a loose connection.
很好。哦，抱歉。请继续。肖恩，说完。就是那样。就是那样。杰森，你的性爱戏呢？我的连接有点松。
Can you guys hear me okay? Yeah. I'm not fine. The wire keeps coming out. And can you hear me? Yeah. And is it in? I guess that's the big.
你们能听清我说话吗？是啊。我不行。线一直掉出来。你们能听到吗？是啊。插进去了吗？我想那是最大的。
Hey, Charlie. You didn't answer, Jason, if you've done a sex scene. I have and I don't like them and it's just, you know, all the cliches are true. You have a, there's a very difficult line one has to ride, which is, you know, if you're into it and you're being passionate convincingly, things start to move, guys. And if they don't move, there's that classic saying that one of the actors said, I apologize if I get aroused and I apologize if I don't get aroused or something like that. It's like, it's a concern.
嘿，查理。你没回答，杰森，如果你拍过性爱场景的话。我拍过，我不喜欢它们，这只是，你知道，所有的陈词滥调都是真的。你有一条非常困难的界限要走，就是，你知道，如果你沉浸其中，并且表现得令人信服地充满激情，事情就开始移动了，伙计们。如果它们不动，有一句经典的话，其中一个演员说，如果我勃起了我道歉，如果我没勃起我也道歉，之类的。这就像，这是一个顾虑。
It's a concern. Well, Bateman, we did this movie called Horrible Bosses, it was a massive global hit will. And you had a little sex scene with Aniston, right? That was the first thing. She like mounted you. Yeah. That was the first thing we shot. Oh, wow.
这是一个顾虑。嗯，贝特曼，我们拍了那部叫《恶老板》的电影，那是一个巨大的全球热门，威尔。你和安妮斯顿有一场小小的性爱戏，对吧？那是我们拍的第一件事。她骑在你身上。是啊。那是我们拍的第一件事。哦，哇。
Wow. And that was basically my second time meeting her. I met her at the, at the read through it was like, okay, well, now take all your clothes off and we'll take these provocative photos. But I only found it humiliating, you know, because I was like, ah, man, I should like go to the gym or like, I was like, I'm so sorry, I'm really pasty and doughy over here. And, you know, you're probably not used to an image like this in your sexual scenarios. I had to do a scene in Brother Solomon with Forte where he comes to where we make up at
哇。那基本上是我第二次见她。我在剧本朗读会上见过她，当时就像，好吧，现在脱掉你所有的衣服，我们会拍这些挑衅性的照片。但我只觉得羞辱，你知道，因为我心想，啊，伙计，我应该去健身房，或者，我心想，我很抱歉，我在这里真的很苍白和面团一样。而且，你知道，你可能不习惯在你的性场景中看到这样的形象。我不得不和福特在《所罗门兄弟》里拍一场戏，他来到我们和好的地方，
the end of the movie and I'm in the shower and I come out. So I've just got the little sock on and then nothing else. And then I got to turn in. He and I have to hug while I'm basically, no, let's, for Tracy, let's explain what the sock is. Go ahead. Well, it's, it's basically that, like it's a sock that you put over, it's a thing you put over your junk.
在电影结尾，我在淋浴间，我出来了。所以我只穿了那只小袜子，然后什么都没穿。然后我不得不转身。他和我都得拥抱，而我基本上，不，让我们，对于特蕾西，解释一下袜子是什么。请继续。嗯，它基本上就是，就像它是一只袜子，你把它套在你的家伙上。
All your meats and cheeses get covered. Yeah. It's like, it's a little coin purse that's got a couple of pieces of fishing wire on both sides that go around you as a thong. Yeah. Okay. But it's a new, it's a nude colored and it's made out of like pantyhose and, and with fishing string on it.
你所有的肉和奶酪都被盖住了。是啊。它就像一个小硬币包，两边有几根钓鱼线，像丁字裤一样绕着你。是啊。好吧。但它是裸色的，是用连裤袜做的，还有钓鱼线。
So you can imagine it's just, it's not, it's not comfortable. It's not a good looking thing. And it's, it's difficult at times to fill out. Will. So, well, that was not an issue. It was more of an issue that like it was kind of the, like you said, like, I'm, I'm sorry if I get it aroused and I'm sorry if I don't. And I just thought, boy, this could go either way with Forte.
所以你可以想象，它只是，它不，它不舒服。它不是一个好看的东西。而且有时很难填满。威尔。所以，嗯，那不是问题。更多的问题是，就像你说的，就像，我很抱歉如果我勃起了，我很抱歉如果我没勃起。我只是想，天哪，这和福特在一起可能会有任何一种结果。
I have no idea. Which way did it go? I don't want to, I don't want to say it, but I just, I will have to watch a movie. Let me just say this. I love the guy and you can tell what you've said plenty. Well, you put that to the beat. So Charlie, so talk, so you're doing this romance and comedy. You decide you want to do it.
我不知道。结果如何？我不想，我不想说，但我只是，我将不得不看电影。让我只说这个。我爱那个家伙，你可以看出你已经说了很多。嗯，你把那个放到了节拍上。所以查理，所以谈谈，所以你在做这个浪漫和喜剧。你决定你想做它。
What is the movie? Well, the movie's called, I Want You Back and it's with Jenny Slate and myself. Oh, Mega Talent. She's a talent. Mega Talent. She's pretty good. She's pretty good. Our, our producing buddy, John Ricard produced this movie.
那部电影是什么？嗯，电影叫《我想要你回来》，是珍妮·斯莱特和我演的。哦，超级天才。她是个天才。超级天才。她很不错。她很不错。我们的制片伙伴，约翰·里卡德制作了这部电影。
Another Mega Talent. Yeah. And we've worked together on Horrible Bosses and Fist Fight. And I was talking to John and I was saying, you know, we should find something to do. And he says, he said, I got these two scripts and you should look at them. And he said, but one's a romcom. So you probably don't want to do that. I said, why would I not want to do that?
另一个超级天才。是啊。我们曾在《恶老板》和《拳头打架》中合作过。我和约翰谈过，我说，你知道，我们应该找点事做。他说，他说，我有这两个剧本，你应该看看。他说，但一个是浪漫喜剧。所以你可能不想做那个。我说，我为什么不想做那个？
What a nasty, nasty thing to say. Nasty thing to say. And I loved it. We put it together. It's, it's a really sweet and funny movie. By the way, I didn't have to take my shirt off in it. And I had this sort of conundrum where the character doesn't work out and then he starts working out in the story.
多么刻薄，刻薄的话。刻薄的话。但我很喜欢。我们把它拼凑起来。它是一部非常甜蜜和有趣的电影。顺便说一句，我不用在里面脱掉衬衫。我遇到了这种困境，角色不锻炼，然后在故事中他开始锻炼了。
And I thought, well, which body do I go with? Do I go with the guy who looks like he's not been working out or the guy that looks like he has been working out? And I went with the guy who has not been working out. Yeah. So did you look at the shooting schedule to sort of plan out what kind of shape you'd be in? Cause I do that.
我想，好吧，我选哪个身体？我是选那个看起来没锻炼过的家伙，还是选那个看起来锻炼过的家伙？我选了那个没锻炼过的家伙。是啊。所以你看了拍摄计划来规划你会是什么样的身材吗？因为我这样做。
I mean, for Tracy, these, these, these projects, they take at least six weeks to shoot sometimes 12 or more. And if you know, you got a topless scene on as Will likes to call it, you know, you want to make sure that you're not having a whole lot of soy sauce a few days out, you know? No, I let that go. I, I was like, no, that's not, that's not what the audience wants from me. They don't, they don't want me to pop that shirt off and have rippling abs. They don't want it.
我的意思是，对于特蕾西，这些，这些项目，拍摄至少需要六周，有时12周或更长。如果你知道，你有一个裸露上身的场景，正如威尔喜欢称呼的那样，你知道，你想要确保你在几天前没有吃太多的酱油，你知道？不，我放手了。我，我当时想，不，那不是，那不是观众想从我这里得到的。他们不，他们不想让我脱掉衬衫，露出波浪般的腹肌。他们不想。
They'll be disturbed if they see it. There's nothing funny about a six pack. There's nothing funny about it. And this is a comedy. So Charlie, any, any recent vacays, as we call it in the biz, any, any vacays with the fam? I went to Hawaii. Okay.
如果他们看到它，他们会感到不安。六块腹肌没什么好笑的。没什么好笑的。这是一部喜剧。所以查理，最近有什么假期吗，我们在行内称之为假期，和家人一起的假期？我去了夏威夷。好吧。
I knew that. I knew that. Oh yeah. You sent us a shot of that beautiful. You sent that pic in our little chain. Oh yeah. I did. I did.
我知道。我知道。哦，是啊。你发给我们一张那美丽的镜头。你把那张照片发到了我们的小群里。哦，是啊。我发了。我发了。
That's right. So you went to Hawaii. Did you go by yourself or did you bring your wife and child? And, and I played a bunch of golf and we hung out and relaxed and went to the beach and, and I reset. It was good. I was coming right off a bunch of things and it was nice to take a break. Charlie 2022.
没错。所以你去了夏威夷。你是自己去的，还是带了妻子和孩子？而且，我打了很多高尔夫球，我们闲逛、放松，去了海滩，我重置了。那很好。我刚结束一堆事情，休息一下很好。查理2022。
What are you most excited about? Oh man. I don't know. I'm, I'm always pretty just excited to be doing this. I mean, I don't know. I'm still grateful. More of the same. Yeah.
你最期待什么？哦，伙计。我不知道。我总是很兴奋能做这件事。我的意思是，我不知道。我仍然很感激。更多同样的事情。是啊。
And polishing up a movie for a good four years that I directed that Bateman was kind enough to be in. Yeah. When do we get to see that Charlie? Any minute. I'm right around the corner, but I was going to sell it. I was in the process of selling it to a studio and I was having some conversations with a very talented man, Mr. Guillermo del Toro.
还有打磨一部我导演了整整四年的电影，贝特曼很慷慨地参与了。是啊。我们什么时候能看到那个，查理？随时。我就在拐角处，但我打算卖掉它。我正在把它卖给一家制片厂的过程中，我正在和一位非常有才华的人，吉列尔莫·德尔·托罗先生进行一些对话。
And I had to change a heart and I took the movie and I reshot about 20% of it. Am I still in it? You're still in it. I'm going to cut. That's been a maddening long experience, but I'm really happy with the movie. So hopefully I'll get it out to the world this year. I'm excited about that. I'm excited about this rom-com.
我改变了主意，我拿回了电影，重拍了大约20%。我还在里面吗？你还在里面。我要剪辑。那是一段令人抓狂的漫长经历，但我对这部电影非常满意。所以希望我今年能把它推向世界。我很期待那个。我很期待这部浪漫喜剧。
I'm excited about maybe getting some golf in with the boys here. Yeah. That's good. And Horrible Buses 3, I think we can announce. Well, now why didn't we do it? You know? Well, because, you know, yeah, because Horrible Buses 2 just basically, you know, cratered. Did it?
我很期待也许能和这里的伙计们打打高尔夫球。是啊。那很好。还有《恶老板3》，我想我们可以宣布。嗯，那我们为什么没做呢？你知道？嗯，因为，你知道，是啊，因为《恶老板2》基本上，你知道，崩溃了。是吗？
Did it shoot the bed? No, it didn't shoot the bed. It's a huge hit. Oh, that's true. Yeah. It didn't do as well as the first. Oh, you mean by pandemic standards? Yeah, that's right.
它搞砸了吗？不，它没搞砸。它是一个巨大的热门。哦，那是真的。是啊。它没有第一部做得那么好。哦，你是说按照大流行的标准？是啊，没错。
But the standards of everybody staying home and not going into theaters are different. Well, I would like the third one because I really, really like to collect those sets. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Things do happen in three. Maybe we just make it for a price, you know, but it did turn out people just didn't give shit about a second one. So they're really not going to want a third.
但每个人都待在家里不去电影院的标准是不同的。嗯，我想要第三部，因为我真的，真的很喜欢收集那些系列。是啊。哦，是啊。事情确实会发生三次。也许我们只是按价格制作它，你知道，但结果人们确实不在乎第二部。所以他们真的不会想要第三部。
It's not really a story that needed a second one. Hear me out. I mean, Horrible Buses 3, but there are two new, Sean, right? Two new guys who look, they're kind of, they just go, ah, my boss is terrible. Hey, my boss is bad too. Are you a boss or you're an employee? Exactly. But the catch phrase is my boss is bad three.
这不是一个真正需要第二部的故事。听我说。我的意思是，《恶老板3》，但有两个新的，肖恩，对吧？两个新家伙，他们看起来，他们有点，他们只是说，啊，我的老板太糟糕了。嘿，我的老板也很糟糕。你是老板还是员工？没错。但口头禅是我的老板很糟糕三。
Yeah. Same here. I get it, Sean. I get it. So Charlie, listen, you're just, you're such a talent. You're divine. You're a good guy. You're a theater.
是啊。我也是，肖恩。我明白了，肖恩。所以查理，听着，你真是个天才。你是神圣的。你是个好人。你是个剧院。
You're a theater major. You're a musician. You're a musician. You're a musician. You're a great marriage. Great marriage. Charming little kid. Your new movie, I Want You Back.
你是戏剧专业的。你是音乐家。你是音乐家。你是音乐家。你有一段伟大的婚姻。伟大的婚姻。迷人的小孩子。你的新电影，《我想要你回来》。
Your romcom is out. I can't wait to see it. And it's on Amazon now. It's really good. I actually love this movie a lot. Charlie. Charlie, I love you. Charlie, thank you for being here.
你的浪漫喜剧出来了。我迫不及待想看它。它现在在亚马逊上。它真的很好。我其实非常喜欢这部电影。查理。查理，我爱你。查理，谢谢你来到这里。
We see you on the golf course probably in the next few days. Well, you're teeing off in about what, 10 minutes? Yeah, this is already six minutes into my heart out. Yeah. Okay. He's kind of heart out. He loves you. He never does this if he's got a heart out for golf as you know.
我们可能在接下来的几天里在高尔夫球场见到你。嗯，你大约在什么，10分钟后开球？是啊，这已经是我心里的六分钟了。是啊。好吧。他有点心里话。他爱你。如果他有高尔夫的心里话，他从不这样做，你知道。
I appreciate the six minutes over. That's good. Can you know how persnickety Jason is about everything? My range time. I need my range time. Yeah. Well, we can come back. I can come back.
我很感激多出的六分钟。那很好。你知道杰森对每件事有多挑剔吗？我的练习场时间。我需要我的练习场时间。是啊。好吧，我们可以回来。我可以回来。
We'll finish this off. Next time you're on the podcast, we'll talk about the time when we were coming down 18 and the guy had charged Jason's Tesla. Who? We'll save that. I had a two hour drive ahead of me. Yeah. It didn't do well.
我们会结束这个。下次你上播客时，我们会谈谈当我们下到18号洞时，那个人给杰森的特斯拉充电的事。谁？我们会留着那个。我前面有两个小时的车程。是啊。它表现不好。
You made him give him his... My 20 back. 20 back. Yeah. And then we never... I gave him 20 just because I felt bad. He got yelled at so much. Jason, you don't know this, but Charlie and I both tipped the guy after you took the tip.
你让他给了他……我的20块钱。20块钱。是啊。然后我们从来……我给了他20块，只是因为我感到难过。他被骂得太惨了。杰森，你不知道这一点，但在你拿走小费后，查理和我俩都给了那个人小费。
Are you kidding me? No. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, we felt bad. Well, we don't want to write a story like fucking Jason. I mean, you were his hero.
你在开玩笑吗？不。是啊。是啊。是啊。嗯，我们感到难过。嗯，我们不想写一个像他妈的杰森那样的故事。我的意思是，你是他的英雄。
You were his hero. He fucking good. At least $20. I should have taken more out of his pocket, son of a bitch. I will say to your credit, you did preemptively tip the guy and say, hey, do you mind taking care of this? He said, great, and then he didn't do it. Right. So it's like, well, I'm going to pay you for the valet parking, but the extra juice for
你是他的英雄。他他妈的好。至少20美元。我应该从他口袋里拿走更多，这个狗娘养的。我得说，值得称赞的是，你确实先发制人地给了那个人小费，并说，嘿，你介意处理一下这个吗？他说，太棒了，然后他没做。对吧。所以就像，嗯，我会为你支付代客泊车费，但额外的报酬是为了
doing me a solid, which you didn't do, that then means that you no longer need the money for that. Yeah. Let me ask you this. If you had shot like even par that day, like your best round ever, do you think you would have cared? Do you think you would have been? I would have given him a ride wherever he wanted to go and all the money in my pocket.
帮我一个忙，你没做，那意味着你不再需要那笔钱了。是啊。让我问你这个。如果你那天打出了平标准杆，就像你最好的成绩一样，你觉得你会介意吗？你觉得你会吗？我会让他去任何他想去的地方，并把我口袋里所有的钱都给他。
And that is Jason Bateman. Guys, we'll be right back with a new episode of smartlets. He loves his golf. He loves his golf. Charlie. Thank you. Enjoy the rest of your day. Great.
那就是杰森·贝特曼。伙计们，我们马上回来，带来新一集的《SmartLess》。他爱他的高尔夫。他爱他的高尔夫。查理。谢谢。享受你剩下的一天。太棒了。
See your faces, fellas. Sean, let's hang out sometime. I don't know. I'm right here just for you. Not worth it, Charlie. No. No. It's got to be better.
见到你们的脸，伙计们。肖恩，我们什么时候聚聚。我不知道。我就在这里，只为你。不值得，查理。不。不。必须更好。
Bring the slide whistle. Next two weeks, Texas. Let's get out. Okay. I'm busy, but you know, we'll see. Yeah. All right. All right.
带上滑哨。接下来的两周，德克萨斯。我们出去吧。好吧。我很忙，但你知道，我们会看到的。是啊。好吧。好吧。
All right. He's about to slam the wrap top. He's going to do the good out. Why? Because I'll tell you why I wasn't going to do it. Because Sean Penn did it. And then I remember I was listening to that. I was like, wow, Sean Penn did it.
好吧。他正要猛地合上笔记本电脑。他要做那个好的结束。为什么？因为我告诉你为什么我不打算做它。因为肖恩·潘做了。然后我记得我在听那个。我心想，哇，肖恩·潘做了。
That's how I'm doing. I think I've done it ever since then. I was like, well, Sean Penn just slams it down. Just slam it down. That's how you do it. So I'm going to slam it down. Bye. Bye.
我就是这么做的。我想从那以后我就一直这么做。我心想，嗯，肖恩·潘只是猛地合上它。只是猛地合上它。这就是你怎么做的。所以我打算猛地合上它。再见。再见。
Oh, look, he really did it. That Charlie day is, he's always a breath of fresh air. Every time you see him, you feel better. He's like, we could change his middle name to sunny, right? So just Charlie sunny day. Yeah. Always a sunny day. Yeah.
哦，看，他真的做了。那个查理·戴，他总是一股清新的空气。每次你见到他，你都会感觉更好。他就像，我们可以把他的中间名改成“阳光”，对吧？所以只是查理·阳光·戴。是啊。总是一个阳光明媚的日子。是啊。
And Charlie. So Sean, you don't know Charlie. You've never met him personally. I never met him. I did that one voiceover of Monster's University with him. But of course, you know, as you know, when you do animated films, you don't really see the other actor because you're doing it a lot. What?
还有查理。所以肖恩，你不认识查理。你从来没见过他本人。我从来没见过他。我和他一起做了那个《怪兽大学》的配音。但当然，你知道，正如你所知，当你制作动画电影时，你并没有真正看到其他演员，因为你做了很多。什么？
Yeah. So I never really met him before. Right. But I'm a huge fan. And I don't know if you've seen Monster's University, but he steals the movie. He's hilarious. Yeah, of course.
是啊。所以我从来没真正见过他。对吧。但我是一个超级粉丝。我不知道你有没有看过《怪兽大学》，但他偷走了整部电影。他太搞笑了。是啊，当然。
First of all, if you've got, if you're a fan of comedy or a fan of animation or you've got kids, you've seen Monster's University. It's a great movie and he is great in it. And you are, but he is, but no, it's a great movie. And he is such a, I met him the first time was through his wife, through me, Mary Elizabeth Ellis, who's such a talent and so cool. And he's a super nice guy, super real.
首先，如果你有，如果你是喜剧迷或动画迷，或者你有孩子，你一定看过《怪兽大学》。那是一部很棒的电影，他在里面很棒。而且你是，但他确实是，但不，那是一部很棒的电影。他是一个如此，我第一次见到他是通过他的妻子，通过我，玛丽·伊丽莎白·埃利斯，她非常有才华，非常酷。他是一个超级好的人，超级真实。
And he joked about being down to earth. He legitimately is. And then he's going and then he's incredibly talented. Yeah, I love him. And prolific writer in just everything. And he's so funny. He's so naturally funny. You guys got that.
他开玩笑说自己脚踏实地。他确实是。然后他去，然后他非常有才华。是啊，我爱他。而且是一位多产的作家，几乎在所有方面。他太搞笑了。他天生就很搞笑。你们俩都有。
You guys both have very unique voices. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. He's got a very unique voice. I don't know if I would consider myself to, but he, he does. Wait. Nobody ever bites, nobody ever bites my, for my theater stories.
你们俩都有非常独特的声音。是的。是啊。是啊。他有一个非常独特的声音。我不知道我是否会认为自己有，但他，他有。等等。从来没有人咬，从来没有人咬我的，为了我的剧院故事。
Cause I, Huh. Number one. So when we save it for a podcast, no one wants to listen to. Okay. What's funny is that you don't take from that. Like maybe I should stop asking.
因为我，嗯。第一。所以当我们把它留给播客时，没人想听。好吧。有趣的是你没有从中吸取教训。就像也许我应该停止询问。
I'm telling you. Your takeaway is nobody bites. No, I'm telling you. Somebody's going to come with a really funny theater story. I think they're always so funny. I like that. Usually your question about funny theater stories ends up with you telling a funny theater story. I know.
我告诉你。你的收获是没人咬。不，我告诉你。有人会带着一个非常有趣的剧院故事来。我觉得它们总是那么有趣。我喜欢那个。通常你关于有趣剧院故事的问题最终会以你讲一个有趣的剧院故事结束。我知道。
It's just, it's a self set up. Jason, you missed John the other day. Robert and I kept pimping him out to tell funny stories for everybody at dinner. Funny theater stories. He kept, so he finding theater stories and he kept getting up and telling these hilarious. They were legitimately hilarious. And he got so worked up. He had to go to the hospital.
这只是，这是一个自我设置。杰森，你前几天错过了约翰。罗伯特和我一直在怂恿他给晚餐时的每个人讲有趣的故事。有趣的剧院故事。他一直，所以他发现剧院故事，他一直站起来讲这些搞笑的。它们确实非常搞笑。他太激动了。他不得不去医院。
I did. That's a true story. It's a true story. So all of a sudden, So all of a sudden Jen comes and she goes, Sean just went to the hospital. I'm like, what? You know, next time I bring up a theater story,
我去了。这是一个真实的故事。这是一个真实的故事。所以突然间，所以突然间珍来了，她说，肖恩刚去了医院。我心想，什么？你知道，下次我提起剧院故事时，
maybe someone will bite, bite. Bite. Bite. Oh bite. Yes. Got it. Not that works. That qualifies.
也许有人会咬，咬。咬。咬。哦咬。是的。明白了。那行不通。那符合条件。
Love you guys. Bye. Bye. Now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
爱你们。再见。再见。现在在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple播客或Wondry应用程序中的Wondry Plus提前无广告收听。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。